Assassin's Creed has a turbulent past
the series reached its peak back in 2009
with Assassin's Creed 2 and has since
tried to recapture the magic sure there
have been some standout games in recent
years like Black Flag but there have
also been some flops like unity with
Assassin's Creed origins it's clear that
Ubisoft is taking big steps in order to
give the Assassin's Creed franchise the
shot in the arm it desperately needs now
if you're a games come this year you can
play the same demo I did but if not
don't forget to subscribe that way you
won't miss any of our games comm 2017
coverage Assassin's Creed origins is a
prologue to the entire series it takes
place in ancient Egypt while Cleopatra
is ascending the throne
you play as byuk a Magi warrior
intertwine in the politics of the era as
with every Assassin's Creed protagonist
byuk is fast quiet and deadly and you're
free to tackle any given situation as
you see fit I typically linked or my bow
for most encounters but there was a good
variety of both heavy and light melee
weapons one of origins biggest changes
is the combat I hate making this
comparison oh so very much but it plays
a lot like Dark Souls light rather than
chaining together a series of pairing
and countering animations like in
previous AC games you're in control of
every swing this means you need to know
the range and the speed of your weapon
otherwise your enemy will get the upper
hand and the best way to create an
opening in your enemies attacks are by
dodging and rolling learning attack
animations and knowing when to dodge is
key based on the demos I've played the
combat is far more engaging than in
previous Assassin's Creed games I felt
more like a player than a spectator as I
timed my attacks and dodges the changes
to combat also forced me to be more
aware of my surroundings who I was
fighting and what weapon I should use
unfortunately combat isn't as tight as
it could be the effectiveness of my
dodge role felt inconsistent at times
when I had time to my dodge perfectly
I'd still get hit fortunately origins
isn't nearly as demanding as a Souls
game so this shouldn't ignite any
fits of rage but it could be an issue in
fighting higher-level enemies however
the biggest draw for me is the setting
Assassin's Creed has always been about
time in place and origins is no
different
seeing Egypt during this ancient time
period is breathtaking at times the demo
area was limited to a small section of a
huge map but there is still a staggering
amount of detail seeing NPCs go about
their business in bustling marketplaces
makes the world feel alive and now that
Ubisoft has opted to remove the mini-map
in favor of an unobtrusive Skyrim like
compass I am far more engaged in the
world and my surroundings rather than
honing in on small symbols that pop up
on the map
unfortunately the occasional bug like a
chicken falling from the sky or a pesky
character walking through a cutscene can
break the immersion but hopefully the
kinks get worked out upon full release
otherwise we might end up with another
Assassin's Creed unity but my biggest
concern with origins is its story in
writing since Ezio the series hasn't had
a particularly strong protagonist and
byuk didn't make a great first
impression he's very serious and seems
to follow his credo rigorously he's not
all that interested in what's going on
around him either he just kind of did
things because a character told him to
my ex-wife on the other hand was a bit
more interesting she wasn't as reserved
as byuk and willing to break some rules
in order to get what she wants to
protect Egypt I would kill a thousand
priests
you and I are pledged to violence now
and always it could be interesting to
see how they play off each other over
the course of the game
assassin's creed origin seems like a
huge improvement over previous games but
if the writing falls flat I don't know
if it will leave behind the same legacy
that Assassin's Creed - and to a lesser
extent Black Flag did before it but
we'll find all that out on October 27th
when the game launches on ps4 Xbox and
PC if you have any specific questions
about my time with the game feel free to
reach out on Twitter at Jacob deck and
for more games comm coverage don't
forget to subscribe